let's say that we have two parallel
lines so that's one line right over
there and then this is the other line
that is parallel to the first one I'll
draw it as parallel as I can so these
two lines are parallel so I'll this is
the symbol right over here to show that
these two lines are parallel and then
let me draw a transversal here so let me
draw a transversal this is also a line
now let's say that we know that this
angle right over here is 110 degrees
what other angles can we figure out here
well the first thing that we might
realize is that look corresponding
angles are equivalent this angle the
angle between this parallel line and the
transversal is going to be the same as
the angle between this parallel line of
the transversal so this right over here
is also going to be 110 degrees now we
also know that vertical angles are
equivalent so this is 110 degrees then
this angle right over here on the
opposite side of the intersection is
also going to be 110 degrees and we
could use that same logic right over
here to say that if this is 110 degrees
and this is also 110 degrees we could
have also said that look this angle
right over here corresponds to this
angle right over here so that they also
will have to be the same now what about
these other angles so this angle right
over here it's outside ray I guess you
could say for is forms aligned with this
angle right over here this pink angle is
supplementary to this 110 degree angle
so this pink angle plus 110 is going to
be equal to 180 or we know that this
pink angle is going to be 70 degrees and
then we know that it achill angle it's a
vertical angle with this angle right
over here so this is also 70 degrees
this angle that's kind of right in below
this parallel line with the transversal
at the bottom left I guess you could say
corresponds to this bottom left angle
right over here so this is also 70
degrees and we could have also figured
that out by saying hey this angle is
supplementary to this angle right over
here and then we could use multiple
arguments the vertical angle argument
the supplementary argument two ways or
the corresponding angle argument to say
that hey
must be 70 degrees as well